the whole process really lacks
transparency right people deserve having
that transparency because ultimately
it's the people who will decide who our
Democratic nominee will be and
ultimately who our next president
commander-in-chief will be and when you
see that lack of transparency it creates
you know a lack of faith and trust in
the process its primetime television if
you want to be anybody in the Democratic
Party you better make sure you get on
this stage at the presidential debates
so what do you need to do to make it two
things first get over a hundred and
thirty thousand unique donations to get
at least two percent in a national poll
ah but here's where it gets tricky not
every poll is the same and if the
Democratic National Committee doesn't
like you they can reject the poll
results that show things in your favor
now Tolson Gabbard has met the donations
threshold she's got over two percent in
26 different national polls
however the Democratic National
Committee says that doesn't count they
have their certified lists sure it's
important to vet information that's
being provided but let's take a quick
look at some of the polls that were
rejected Politico The Economist Reuters
if these widely respected outlets and
news agencies aren't credible in America
then who is polling in the United States
there is a club a network of close
associates and friends and they frown
upon those polls that are either new or
are not members of the club or the
Association so I would certainly
speculate that that has something to do
with it it is a partisan organization
the Democratic National Committee so any
polls say that may have a tradition of
leaning Republican or not considered to
be in the mainstream of democratic
partisanship you know would be would be
ruled out even the polls deemed credible
by the Democratic Party have a margin of
error of between two and six percent and
when the criteria for being in the
debates is only two percent a margin of
error like that is a pretty big deal so
Tulsi Gabbard could have between zero
and seven
percent support among American voters
now keep in mind there are over 200
million people who are registered to
vote in the United States of America so
what's the difference between 0 and 14
million well whatever it is it is
apparently not important to the
Democratic National Committee there is a
margin of sampling error so if the
margin of error is plus or minus 4% what
is 2% in the polls
if if it's 1.5 1% that the candidate has
that does get rounded up to 2% whereas a
1.4 4% which is meaningless one can
argue the Democratic National Committee
is a private organization we can
establish our own rules but then they
also have to be open to the charges by
somebody like Tulsi Gabbard who says
this doesn't smell like it's fair and
frankly I agree with her I don't think
it smells like it's fair now the DNC
doesn't exactly have a reputation for
impartiality and fairness leaked emails
in 2016
showed that the Democratic Party leaders
were working pretty hard to defeat
Bernie Sanders and make sure that it was
Hillary Clinton who ultimately took on
Donald Trump now after the outrage in
2016 the new Democratic party chair Tom
Perez promised to empower grassroots
activists I am more committed than ever
before to restoring voters faith in our
democratic process because even the
perception of impartiality or an unfair
advantage undermines our ability to win
that is unacceptable
to that end the new DNC under my
leadership is committed to the task of
making sure that our 2020 nominating
process will be unquestionably fair and
transparent so as the list of candidates
gets whittled down to one final nominee
voters will have to decide as to whether
mr. Perez is living up to his promise
caleb Maupin RT New York
you